my son calls me boomer all the time and
everything i do he says boomer boomer
and i looked it up i'm not a boomer are
you not well they tech generation x no i
think i should be i'm right on the line
between a boomer and gen x and i don't
like it i think the line runs right
through like 1963
which is when i'm born
and so
i think of a boomer as someone who was
at woodstock okay and i was pooping my
diapers at woodstock i mean i was 30 but
uh i get it folks um but i mean i don't
uh i think of boomers as people that
were saying yeah i'm going off to see
crosby stills nash and young i'll be
back later and then i'm going to join
the manson cult to me that's a boomer
okay i'm seeing here that the boomers
are 1946 to 64. so
you are a boomerang but wow listen i'm
so soundly in the middle of the
generation x generation that i can let
you in but you have to be asked in like
a vampire so you got to start being nice
to me and you know can i be able to can
i be a gen xer please is there a test
yeah there's a bit of a test okay well i
don't like you admit i did get screwed a
little bit on the timing of i think 64
is going way too late for boomers
because how can a boomer encompass
someone who was born just as world war
ii is ending and me that's ridiculous
who came of age you know watching
scooby-doo cartoons that's insane that's
way too yet there is a divide between
you and me look i'm wearing flannel like
a grunge guy everything about you says
grunge
everything everything about you
says i just remember
you were there in 91 in seattle remember
when it was all going down oh yeah you
can see you in the background a lot
i was in whittier listening to wilson
phillips
it's so funny whenever i hear whittier i
think of nixon you know yeah you grew up
blocks from nixon's house and i just
love that you used to listen to wilson
phillips with an aging richard nixon
would you come over your house oh
is matt here uh yes former president
nixon he's uh he's he's in the basement
is it every listening time actually
listen to wilson phillips yes he is
listening to wilson's phone i'd very
much like to join him down here i think
it's a quite a trio
are you a carnie or a china i'm
i like china eyes good god the gams on
that lady
are we taping this by the way
first podcast that was the first podcast
ever you could argue was the nixon tapes
that's the first podcast yeah yeah you
remember when you listened to the nixon
tapes i don't because i wasn't alive as
i was a generation actually i know your
generation extra but they're called
tapes and you can listen to them later
on
i know yeah yeah so you're probably
unfamiliar with anything um i'll tell
you about glenn miller someday there's
actually a way to listen to that music
even though you weren't alive at the
time but you know think about it the
nixon tapes really are the first podcast
and it would have been very funny if he
had done it if you were listening to it
and you heard him doing at taking a
break to do ads yeah so he's talk he's
so nixon's in the oval office and he's
talking to haldeman and erlickman and
he's like well you know we got to get
these these bastards we got to get them
where it hurts well how much money would
it cost uh to get in to break into the
watergate hotel well we could we have a
team that would do it and it would cost
about this much well we could get that
money yeah we could get that money yeah
well just uh hang on just a second here
i just remember puts me in mind of uh
i'm looking at a photograph here of my
lovely wife pat and i'm thinking
wouldn't it be nice if this this
photograph was on glass
[Laughter]
let me tell you it can be fracture
prints with fracture prints you'll get
this wonderful
picture of pat or or one of the
eisenhower boys
or your dog checkers you can have it on
class
so that when pat boone comes by the oval
office to swap stories you can show them
pictures and they're on glass preserve
for all time anyway fracture anyway back
to you erlichman alderman how do we get
these [ __ ] we gotta get in there and
we've gotta get i gotta get those
goddamn pentagon papers back there's
gotta be a way to store papers and i'll
tell you one thing if you wanna keep
track of papers you'll need the right
software to do it and that's software
i don't even i wish conan was a better
improviser and could come up with a
[ __ ] company
what is it matt what's a good software
company quickbooks there you go
quickbooks oh yeah quickbooks software
that way you can keep track you can get
the pentagon papers at
daniel ellsberg's soul
you can get them to keep on quicken you
can also keep track of all your slush
funds with their accounting app
and this enables you to then take that
money and you can send it to those
cubans right away without having to put
it through the mail anyway back to the
podcast today's episode we're gonna get
those [ __ ]
those [ __ ] were gonna hit him and hit
him hard
i swear to god i can do nine hours
that's nixon's podcast please if you
liked nixon's podcast riff
please encourage me to do it some more
because i've never been happier